good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight this is a bewildering
moment as we often note
what exactly is going on
there's a pattern if you look around for
a moment you may notice things that add
up gas lines inflation spiraling crime
collapsing cities if you're over 40 it
could look familiar
it's the 1970s but without the free
speech and brezhnev running our
government
and as if it could get more perfect now
we may have another fall of saigon
remember the fall of saigon if you're
watching television of april of 1975
april 30th you remember it well it was
the single most humiliating day in the
history of the united states abroad
american officials fleeing in terror as
a peasant army threat swept through the
capital city desperate civilians
clinging to the struts of helicopters as
they took off from the roof of the u.s
embassy it was a complete disaster it
was total ignominious defeat
we'd spent more than a decade in vietnam
and in the end we lost
so no matter how you fell felt about
that war it was painful to see it happen
and nobody wants to see it again
last month joe biden promised we never
will see it again watch
some vietnamese veterans see echoes of
their experience in this withdrawal in
afghanistan do you see any parallels
between this withdrawal and what
happened in vietnam with some people
feeling whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof
of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
yeah it's not comparable the difference
joe biden told us is that in afghanistan
we can rely on the afghan security
forces to keep the savages at bay these
are crack troops they've gotten billions
in u.s tax dollars over 20 years and by
the way they were trained by mark mille
he's now the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff so we're good don't
worry
last month mark milley himself led his
personal stamp of approval to the afghan
security forces watch
the afghan security forces have the
capacity
to sufficiently fight
and defend their country
and we will continue to support the
afghan security forces where necessary
in accordance with the guidance from the
president and the secretary of defense
the future of afghanistan is squarely
in the hands of the afghan people
and there are a range of possible
outcomes
in afghanistan and i want to emphasize
repeatedly and i've said this before
a negative outcome a taliban automatic
military takeover is not a foregone
conclusion
it's not a foregone conclusion actually
at this point a military takeover by the
taliban is starting to look like a
foregone conclusion taliban fighters now
have control over a majority of the
country including the second largest
city tonight kandahar the government
meanwhile controls just about 15 percent
of the districts in afghanistan the
taliban have now isolated the capital
kabul at this point they are 30 miles
away
analysts say kabul could fall within
days right now thousands of american
troops are on their way there to
evacuate the u.s embassy
our helicopters flew into the city just
this afternoon they're not on the roof
yet
but it's early
the funny thing is mark milley didn't
seem to see any of this coming his real
expertise as he explained recently to
congress is something called white rage
the taliban by contrast are slightly
tanner so they didn't seem as dangerous
as say the january 6th protesters now
the taliban voted for donald trump so
mark milley naturally underestimated
them
but others saw very clearly what was
coming three years ago the inspector
general for afghan reconstruction found
that the afghan government controlled or
had influence over just half the country
that's it in other words afghanistan has
been unstable for a very long time
always actually
and yet the pentagon repeatedly told us
otherwise we're on the right track now
said jim mattis in 2010
four years later another general quote
the afghan national security forces are
winning
so based on those confident assessments
officials in washington spent more than
130 billion dollars on nation building
there
for
some perspective that's more than we
spent on the entire marshall plan in
europe after the world was destroyed in
1945.
so you've got to ask yourself where did
all that money go
the pentagon of course isn't really sure
where all that money went but internal
documents suggest it was wasted the
afghan papers you remember those they
make it clear that a lot of that money
went
to the most corrupt people in the
country
those documents show that only about two
in ten afghan recruits in the fabled
security forces could read or write that
meant among other things they could not
reliably follow orders and apparently
they haven't been for years meanwhile
afghan commanders have routinely
pocketed taxpayer money from the united
states with so-called ghost soldiers
those are troops who appeared on the
payroll but didn't actually exist
one recent assessment found that between
50 and 70 percent of police positions in
some afghan provinces weren't really
alive they weren't people they existed
only on paper
did mark millie know this
the troops who did exist sometimes use
their weapons to commit crimes and shoot
american troops or officials
one norwegian observer estimated that
more than 30 percent of afghan police
recruits would take their guns and quote
set up their own private checkpoints to
extort travelers
between 2007 and 2013 insider attacks
from afghan forces killed or injured
hundreds of coalition troops
these were signs of a major problem
other soldiers again with money that we
sent them begin to sexually abuse
children according to a piece in the new
york times quote rampant sexual abuse of
children has long been a problem in
afghanistan particularly among armed
commanders who dominate much of the
rural landscape and can bully the
population the practice is called
baccabazi literally boy play and
american soldiers and marines have been
instructed not to intervene in some
cases not even when their afghan allies
have abused boys on military bases
so all this was going on sex abuse on
our american military bases but the
pentagon maintained publicly that
everything was going just according to
plants you can see why this comes as
quite a surprise to us those of us who
took those assurances at face value
in fact it was just a couple days ago in
fact it was two days ago on wednesday at
the top flack at the pentagon the
increasingly ridiculous john kirby
insisted that the us military has turned
afghanistan into a kind of progressive
utopia it's santa monica in the
mountains
i've been watching this
from a very early period right after the
president gave us the order to draw down
we certainly have been watching what the
taliban is doing we we have noted and we
have noted with great concern uh the
speed with which they have been moving
um and the
um
and the lack of resistance that they
have faced and we have been nothing but
honest about that and i think i'll leave
it there
so today john kirby called on the people
of afghanistan to rise up and fight for
the social justice that we have brought
them the women's rights victories the
afghan government has secured
right
meanwhile the actual country quite apart
from our social engineering projects is
collapsing at high speed you're seeing
pictures on your screen right now from
kunduz air base the taliban now controls
it so that's tens of millions of dollars
maybe hundreds of millions worth of mine
resistant vehicles humvees drones that
the pentagon left behind in afghanistan
and all of it now belongs to the taliban
yet somehow the bide administration is
still pretending maybe they have no
choice that they're in charge the u.s
embassy in kabul just sent out this
tweet quote we're hearing additional
reports of taliban executions of
surrendering afghan troops deeply
disturbing and could constitute war
crimes
war crimes hilarious so when will the
tribunal start who's going to run the
tribunals we may need to invade
afghanistan again
but instead here's another idea let's
figure out how this happened how did we
spend 20 years trillions of dollars
thousands of american lives to end up
with absolutely nothing but more
humiliation posh tuned tribesmen
shooting at us with our guns as we run
away that is the definition of disaster
so rather than just complain about it
let's hold somebody accountable for it
for once
half the biden state department had a
hand in our failed afghanistan policy
yet they're still employed there why is
that the pentagon was supposed to build
a functional national army in
afghanistan to protect the government
which we installed but they didn't do
that
so people didn't do their jobs and then
lied about not doing their jobs but
they're still wearing the uniform of our
country
why is that good question
so for the first time in a long time
maybe we could hold our own leaders to
account for the calamities they have
caused that's not simply a matter of
justice though it definitely is that
it is the only way to prevent disasters
like this from happening again hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else